foreign
you guys see that okay so I'll do the
other way you're over here and you enter
and then you turn
this one I'm going to use the spiral of
the overall pattern
okay he's going this way and I turn this
way and there he is
yeah
not here
here
different
you just forward progress
to keep the spiral
forward progress
[Music]
emphasize the cast Okay so as I come
around here yeah that's she you can do
shihonaga there you see
so this hand I keep going around it
okay
so you have to keep it going around all
right
you're making what's going forward
backwards to him
foreign
don't don't smell it and come here hi
keep him going around
and then now it's going backwards good
okay but you have to move with this
so you have to go around I can't go here
I go here where the hand is hi you see
now it's going back
it was going forward but once we do the
spiral forward will become backwards so
what you don't do is bring his hand like
this
thing
you make his hand go
like this
this hand keeps going like that on a
smaller Circle and that's how it gets
there okay do you see that so it's not
that I go here and then I make his hand
go like that
I make his hand make a circle around
itself and then it gets there
so it keeps going around
he's gonna go around
[Music]
okay
exaggerating the footwork there okay try
so this variation
this variation
normal Shield
and this variation